nous devions l'obtenir pour la place
[Musique]
c'est agréable de vous rencontrer
merci pour merci de soutenir mon travail et d'
aimer mes livres signifie beaucoup pour moi j'ai
lu Nos étoiles contraires et vous avez écrit
Nos étoiles contraires vous'  je me moque de son
anglais comment est ton français je pourrais je
n'en ai pas envie mais je peux faire un accent
comme peut-être que je suis français mais j'essaie juste
de parler en anglais non non nous nous sommes
mis d'accord je t'aime John je t'aime  aussi laissez-
moi vous dire d'accord merci mec
merci nous sommes très excités par le
film je suis tellement fier de ce que NAT et
Cara ont fait je pensais que Cara je veux dire c'est
évidemment incroyable c'est un acteur brillant
mais comme Cara tu n'as pas toi  je sais que les
gens ne l'ont jamais vue dans des films auparavant
et je pensais qu'elle avait fait un excellent travail
et que toute la distribution était géniale, donc je leur suis vraiment
reconnaissante à chaque fois que vous écriviez une
histoire en choisissant l'une de mes histoires préférées,
alors bien sûr j'ai adoré tout quoi  vous le
faites merci beaucoup je ne sais pas
si vous avez fait le casting mais si vous
savez vraiment comment  choisir les acteurs qu'ils aiment
qu'ils nourrissent vraiment c'est dont je
parlais je ne les ai pas choisis mais ils ont fait
un excellent travail
euh mais oui ils ont tous dit
leurs rôles tellement comme maintenant quand je
pense au radar je pense à la justice
et quand je pense à Ben, je pense à
Austin comme et NAT est juste devenu un repère
pour moi, je veux dire la chose folle à ce sujet,
comme les autres personnages que je n'ai jamais vus, je
n'ai jamais aimé voir le monde à travers leurs
yeux, mais parce que comme repère est le
narrateur de  cette histoire à aimer dans mon
esprit je pense que je sais quel signal sonne comme
tu sais comme je pense que je sais comment son
dialogue sonne et comment il pense et
tout et comme c'est la chose qui m'énervait le
plus mais quand j'ai
regardé le film j'ai juste  j'avais l'impression que NAT avait
compris qu'il comprenait à quoi ressemblait la réplique
pour moi et qu'il avait l'air que ma
réplique sonnait
assez c'était assez génial oh
vous êtes les bienvenus maintenant je vais recommencer à
me moquer parce que quand j'ai lu le livre
j'étais comme  eh bien j'allais b  e dans un
film parce que Q est d'une humeur vraiment spéciale,
ça doit être vraiment pareil et
quand je regarde le film c'est ouais
c'est vraiment
merci ouais maintenant tout à coup nous étions
si gentils avec ça je suis nerveux parce que je
me sens  comme si c'était bon de transformer
n'importe quoi en insulte, donc je ne suis pas impatient d'
aimer céder au compliment, alors je
vais juste dire merci et tu es aussi une
actrice
n'était pas non, elle regarde le plus grand
film à succès et  aussi des amis ouais non sérieusement
comme je sais que j'étais ouvert en attendant
qu'elle le dise elle est comme ça je veux qu'elle se
vante tu sais d'accord ouais je savais que je
voulais juste alors oui un peu c'était comme si mon
premier Johnny avait un film pour  nous
oui oui uh-huh comme zip elle n'aime pas
elle n'est pas tu sais un Atlantic c'est
Minuit à Paris pour les jeunes on est
dans l'hôtel où Minuit à Paris a été
filmé action Oh Midnight Cowboy pour les
jeunes juste tous les minuit  film
pour les jeunes
Midnight Run pour les jeunes ah
Midnight Express ouais je ne k  maintenant, de quoi
vous parlez,
ce sont nos films ouais
en fait depuis le début depuis le
début je suis un chanteur comme vous le savez
vraiment je suis un chanteur et ouais juste
parce que beaucoup de chance un
réalisateur incroyable appelé Eric latigo mm-  hmm
choisis-moi pourquoi je ne sais pas et c'était
mon premier film j'étais au cinéma on pourrait
aimer c'est des
rires froids peut-être que ça veut dire croire Amélie
mais je ne sais pas comment tu penses que
je ne sais pas c'est un  biggie
c'est un animal avec comme des cors RAM Billy
go capacité Je ne sais pas si c'est tracé
c'est là que les mots est-ce une licorne
comme savez-vous ce que vous aimez le plus aimez-
vous chanter ou agir plus les deux
ouais
une fois que vous chantez et agissez les deux  ce que je pourrais
je suis tous les deux
et vous faites un excellent travail donc c'est
génial merci
Dupree moi comme une des voix Army rocky
Lamia voyant Oh Daphne Roger Oliver
notre fils
DiMarco les chevaux ont commencé l'homme L c'est aussi
peut faire la télévision résistivité courage  des
terroristes la vie de Marco 818 changent
Devon pour espérer au développement moderne  pment of
advanced at fields California occupé à
planifier les terminaux une enquête n'est pas une
classe Cupidon contacter un technicien qui est
coupé vous pourriez avoir une blague étaient
assez bons pour affaire sécrétion garder un tampon
Martin Cooper Xcode regarder une vidéo faire
Obama QP Los Cabos
c'est quelqu'un  cela nous a coûté là-bas
magnifique
je m'assiérais à La Jolla vous savez que les
kerbecs de la prison circulent brutalement venez ensemble pour
dire aux dames que vous devriez me dire
Gilda Pepsi un temps de vacances est sur le
sujet de la chaleur pour vraiment confondre une question
mieux vaut couper aux toilettes  dans Mineta
disruptia nagoya à la joie de le mystère
zipper tape ou circulaire flip around
Avenue sur réduire la puissance God review mouth
Gopala Daniel for LMSs a Daniel a
Victoria bahasa ouais j'ai un ami
Amato
je suppose un adjoint da de dum de moi à
dupa elle a dit  moi kefka sauce cogs un
massage catalyser lambda elle essaie de
yadda révéler le coquelicot chacun dans une
version Whovian un crossover gémissant Marcia pauvre
son circuit supporté par la mythologie est un
mannequin du  APB supérieur
tu leur
manques tomando bras yak Lumias pomme NACO
hôpital mine
[Musique]